- [Narrator] Meet streptococcus mutans.
- Hey. My friends call me Strep.
- [Narrator] He's a bacterium
and a bit of a slob.
But this isn't just any mess.
It's what's on your teeth.
You see, strep and all his
roommates live inside your mouth.
Feeding off of the sugar
and protein in your food.
When they're done, they
excrete a slimy substance
all over your pearly whites.
The end result is a bacteria
ridden pigsty called biofilm.
Now, a little biofilm
isn't gonna hurt you.
It's only when you stop brushing it away
that things can get ugly.
And not only for your teeth.
It just so happens that
strep and his friends
are a downright threat to your life.
Nearly half of Americans don't
brush their teeth enough.
And when food builds up in
those nooks and crannies,
you're inviting a host
of bacteria to the party.
Including your gumline.
Which irritate and inflame your gums
causing tenderness and bleeding.
But that's just the start.
Soon enough, that infection
will trigger your immune system
which sends fighter cells
to battle the bacteria.
This creates a hostile
environment for the bacteria.
Which is what you want but
it can also damage the cells
in nearby tissue and bone.
Six months to years later
that tissue and bone
will eventually die.
At this point, you don't
have gingivitis anymore.
You have something much worse:
periodontal disease.
No more tissue and bone means
no more structural support.
So, your gums separate from
your teeth forming pockets
that quickly become extra space
for strep and his friends.
Which further infects your gums
causing your teeth to fall out.
Now, you may think this
could never happen to you
but about 10% of Americans
between ages 50-64
have lost not one, not two,
but all of their teeth.
And to make matters worse,
strep and his buddies may enter
your blood stream where
they'll wreak havoc
on your organs too.
For example, in one study,
people with periodontal disease
were four and a half times
more likely to have chronic
kidney disease than
people with healthy gums.
And another study found that people
in a retirement community who
didn't brush their teeth daily
had up to 65% greater risk of dementia.
Last but not least,
there's an increased risk of
developing certain cancers.
To be fair, these risks
can also be the result
of poor hygiene in general
but the message remains clear.
Brush your teeth.
It's worth the extra four minutes a day.